mike florio pro football talk here on
the rich eisen show what's up mike
rich how are you before we get to the
important aspects of this yes sir you
mentioned davis mills and i just have to
comment and i don't know if you've ever
noticed this there are an inordinate
number of quarterbacks
in the nfl especially backups where you
can take their
first name and make it their last name
and take their last name and make their
first name and it sounds
the same yep there's a bunch of them um
go for it you got any more you know the
ones that you like oh there's plenty of
i mean just you know i was just thinking
guys that were drafted
lawrence trevor if we want to do that
wilson zach if we want to do that i
but it's usually backups like cooper
rush rush cooper
same difference so there's there's a
bunch the list goes on and on wilson's
fun exercise wilson
looks like driving it's like a driving
thing instead of spotting license plates
you think of
quarterbacks whose names can be
interchanged and it sounds just the same
as the name currently is oh man pro
football talks mike florio here on the
rich eisen show i
i literally i'll i'll say on on camera
and into this microphone what i texted
you earlier mike florio
i didn't understand your post but the
one thing i understand about your post
on this subject matter is something
important is in there
to inform something about the texans
and deshaun watson and deshaun watson in
his immediate future in the nfl
what in the world is going on between
his lawyers now that they are publicly
talking
at one another the information that you
got before the draft
and your instincts were accurate they
were trying to settle the cases that's
why
everything got quiet you have the
lawyers at each other's throats with
social media posts
and statements and press conferences and
three weeks ago today they were in court
accusing
each side of destroying evidence and
then after that
as the draft approached it got deathly
science
silent it continued that way and what we
now know
by virtue of the latest instagram post
from tony busby there was
a confidentiality agreement that was
written up to allow them
to engage in settlement talks so
the two parties agreed and i assume that
this thing was eventually signed it was
a document that he claims that rusty
hardin deshaun watson's lawyer put
together
allowing settlement conversations to
occur
under a veil of confidentiality and
that's relevant now because busby is
pointing to that
apparently as his rebuttal to the claim
from rusty harden
that busby is the one who wants
confidentiality and
harden and watson don't but there's a
distinction to be made here it's one
thing to want confidentiality as it
relates to
the settlement discussions it's another
thing to want confidentiality as it
relates to
the outcome of the settlement if you
reach one
and the thing that hardens said
yesterday that i think was very
significant and very telling
as to where this currently stands watson
and harden don't want confidentiality of
the terms of the settlement
busby does according to harden which
turns the whole process on its head
usually the person who writes the check
is the one who wants no one to be able
to talk about anything
right doesn't want others to show up and
say
i want mine all this is a guy who's just
writing checks
the defendant wants to silence when you
flip it around the only
plausible inference is watson's happy to
talk about it which means the amounts
involved aren't all that much and that's
out there now
and i haven't seen anything from busby
that effectively robust that perception
that harden has created
okay so um one thing that also
leapt out at me and i know it did to you
was in busby's
latest instagram statement which is the
first time we're hearing from him
um he said that we obviously didn't
reach out to them
they begged us via the texans
to mediate we hold the cards the truth
sometimes or most of the time hurts
there's four exclamation points there
we approach them question mark
exclamation point question mark
my ass is how it ends uh end quote i
need to say that
so you don't think that that's what i'm
i'm saying to you
mike um so what uh what's up with that
well here's my understanding and i've
actually done some reporting for a
change on this i haven't written it yet
because i have one more phone call i
need to make okay but
but the texans were not involved in any
of these communications
i believe that there's a lawyer who does
work for someone tied to the texans
possibly owner cal mcnair
who wasn't a liaison a go-between and
that's not uncommon
that's not uncommon to get somebody who
can break the ice
because no one wants to be the one to
make the first call in a situation like
this because the first call
can be interpreted as a sign of weakness
by virtue of the fact that the two
lawyers right now
can't agree on who made the first move
if you're the one who's saying
let's talk settlement you're perceived
as the one who really wants to settle
the case that's
that's why this seemingly childish fight
is happening so
i believe that the truth here is that
there's some lawyer out there with
a tie to the texans by way of some sort
of representation
relationship who served as that
that liaison it wouldn't surprise me
buzzby got that factually wrong because
at one point he claimed it was the
texans quarterbacks coach
who had referred watson to one of his
clients when it was watson's private
quarterback coach which is very
different from someone who works
directly for the team so i think that's
how that gets resolved the texans
haven't been involved in this
but it's entirely possible the lawyer
with a relationship with the texans
has worked to to bring the two sides
together so nobody has to be the one
that says hey i'd really like to settle
this case
so that's the issue now is now that this
has all been out there where
watson as you point out in your post and
his side can say
hey you know now that it's confidential
and we don't know the terms
you knew i wanted you to know the terms
of it and so it's not that much money so
there's nothing
to really see here in terms of my
reputation being tarnished or what have
you
certainly if that's another way to say
to the nfl don't suspend me for too much
um so now that that's been put out there
for watsonside and busby
can sit here and say we we hold all the
cards that you know we've got everything
you know going for us can the reason why
i'm having you on to to go through all
of this sort of slinging
uh of of mud is to say is this something
that you
think based on your knowledge of the nfl
and of course the legal system
is something that can be settled now
leading to watson elsewhere this summer
yes rich absolutely and i think what can
happen now and i think the next move in
all of this
is for hardin once this dies down
and i think it will the weekend will
help but once it dies down
harden and watson can say okay fine
we'll agree to the confidentiality that
you have
requested and i don't know whether there
are other
major stumbling blocks toward a
settlement but my understanding was
before any of this came up that the one
big issue
was confidentiality with this
reverse image of what we usually expect
where the defendant wants it and the
plaintiff
either doesn't want it or doesn't care
here the plaintiff's lawyer wants it
the defendant doesn't want it and it
could be that harden has done enough so
that when the cases are settled
folks like us can say well
maybe it wasn't as much as you would
think because remember harden
wanted none of it to be confidential
that may be the genius
in what hardin did yesterday to lay the
foundation to flip
and say okay fine we'll give you
confidentiality now settle the cases
and that perception that watson wrote
six figure checks to 22 different people
just won't be there
okay so then what what would be
the way to getting watson to where he
wants to go
what happens then i mean because to me
like again a team that feels that do do
their due diligence if this is something
that's settled and we find out that
it's untoward behavior it's unseemly
behavior it's behavior that will
definitely stick to desean watson
forever more
um but it doesn't rise to the occasion
of criminal
and and the nfl handles its business in
suspending watson
uh for a few games don't you think a
team would absolutely go in the
direction
of flipping the texans the uh
the the draft capital that nick casario
could say
it's now davis mills is turn here with
tarad taylor what do you think
i know it'll happen i know it'll happen
the moment these cases are settled if it
happens
that's when the land rush begins for the
sean watson contract and
the texans still may get a decent return
because even though this litigation
took a lot of the steam out of the talk
of and somebody told me one point three
first round picks
for deshaun watson ideally if one of
them was a top 10 pick this year
to make it happen that subsided when we
had 22 lawsuits to contend with those go
away
if you get two three four teams at the
table
then the value gets pumped back
into this potential trade and i i know
peter's got the teams that
that he's put on the short list i'd put
the dolphins and the eagles at the top
and the eagles are one that we've been
saying for weeks now you need to keep an
eye on they desperately want a franchise
quarterback
and yes they want to give jalen hurts
the chance this year to show that he's
the guy but if they have an opportunity
to get a guy who's shown
he can do it and have him for ten years
i think they will aggressively try to
make something like that happen
the dolphins have been very quiet about
it but there's a sense that they're
lurking
and you know we never have gotten a wish
list from deshaun watson but
i really think at this point and i don't
know how aggressive he would be with
with exercising his no trade clause and
really every starting quarterback has a
de facto no trade clause because you're
not going to trade for a guy that
doesn't want to be there
right but watson may may be a lot less
picky than he would have been
before all this stuff happened because i
think he'll just be glad to have a
chance to go start up his career
anywhere
before i let you go mike florio um you
know
you were kind enough to post uh about uh
the aaron jones conversation that
occurred right here in this space
uh at this very time actually yesterday
on thursday
and he said you know essentially
the uh adam schefter draft day report
that his teammate
aaron rodgers didn't want to come back
and play for green bay or is telling
people that he was done there
shocked him also told stories about how
rogers was a was mentoring jordan love
during practice you know
helping him out being there for him just
like every other teammate
and i i just was left with the sense of
just throwing my hands up saying i'm no
closer into understanding what the hell
is going on there
are are you well
i i think that really at the end of the
day there's
there's two different sides to this from
rogers perspective i think he decided
last year
after the packers did what they did that
he was not going
to do anything within the building on
the practice field
game day wherever to make it look like
he was troubled by
the arrival of jordan love and that he
would funnel all of that anxiety and
angst and anger toward a positive
season and it worked he was the mvp he
was the best player in football now
after the season all bets were off
and i i think where it stands now is
battle lines are drawn packers are
calling his bluff packers barring some
sort of a change of heart aren't going
to trade him
and i think that when you hear the
comments from guys like john kuhn and
james jones who are being
i think whether they understand it or
not whether they realize it or not
they're being used by rogers as
surrogates to get his message out there
when he talks to them and they talk to
media and say
the situation is fixable that's
basically rogers saying
the situation is fixable and i think
he's going to find a way to show up
and act like everything's fine what's
everybody looking at
is there a booger i'm not aware of you
know and
and then uh and blame us for making a
big deal out of something that he'll
claim wasn't a big deal and then he
plays this year and then we do it all
again next year no way
so then what what is the the there what
you're saying it's jordan love and he
was just able to swallow it
you know uh every single day going to
practice acting the good guy good
soldier
and that's what you're saying because he
knew everybody was watching and waiting
for for whatever we expected angry aaron
rodgers to do
so he was mr positivity all year long i
remember aaron jones telling me that
after their win over the lions when
jones had a huge game over 200 yards
from scrimmage and three touchdowns
he said that aaron's been awesome he
hasn't been upset about anything he's
just motivated and focused and
determined
and that's apparently how he was all
year except when he reportedly was
telling teammates
hey you're about to be a free agent by
the way i'm not going to be here next
year i don't know how that fits into it
right but but but hey he look
at the end of the day rich if they say
to him play for us or play for no one
and playing for no one entails paying
them back almost 30 million dollars
and not continuing one of the greatest
quarterbacking careers in league history
is he really going to not play
he doesn't have an issue with his
teammates he doesn't have an issue with
the coaching staff is he really not
going to play
and then become public enemy number one
in green bay i just i don't think he's
going to do it i think it's
it's brilliant by the packers this box
and there's really no way out for him
other than to play this year who's on
pft pm what do you got
later on today pft pm's on hiatus
oh we're on summer break baby school's
out good
school's out well
that's great beginning my moderate and
responsible consumption at 6 p.m i can
well i really can start technically at
9am but i i wait
it is five o'clock somewhere mike as i'm
sure you've heard that phrase
all right great so have a great weekend
um we'll see you on pro football talk uh
monday morning we'll see you on that yes
bright and early okay man thank you pal
i appreciate it appreciate it too that's
mike florio here
on the rich eisen show hey you watched
all the way to the end thanks for that
watch more right here